قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
ماونينج ان استمرار الازمه الاوكرانيه
يشكل تحديا خطيرا لسلامه وامن المنشاه
النوويه الاوكرانيه ودعت اطراف النزاع الى
الحفاظ على سلامه هذه المنشاه
يشكل استمرار الازمه الاوكرانيه تحديا
خطيرا لسلامه وامن المنشات النوويه
الاوكرانيه ونولي اهميه كبيره لذلك ندعو
الى الحفاظ على سلامه محطات الطاقه
النوويه ومعارضه الهجمات المسلحه على هذه
المحطات وغيرها من المنشات النوويه
السلميه طرح المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه مبادره امن محطه
نوويه نقدر الجهود التي يبذلها ونؤيد جهود
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في القيام
بدور بناء في تعزيز سلامه وامن المنشات
النوويه